what I'd like to do in this video is
start exploring how we can model things
with the differential equations and in
this video in particular we will explore
modeling population modeling population
we're actually going to go into some
depth on this eventually but here we're
going to start with simpler models and
we'll see we will stumble on using the
logic of differential equations things
that you might have seen in your algebra
or your precalculus class so on some
level what we're going to do here is
going to be review but we're going to
get there using the power of modeling
with differential equations so let's
just define some variables let's say
that P is equal to our population and
let's say that T is let's say that T is
equal to the time that has passed in
days in days it could have been years or
months but let's say we're doing the
population of insects that reproduce
quite quickly so days seem like a nice
time spits banned to care about now what
would be a reasonable model well we
could say that the rate of change the
rate of change of our population with
respect to time with respect to time is
well a reasonable thing to say is that
it's going to be proportional to the
actual population the actual population
why is that reasonable well the larger
the population the larger the rate at
any given time if you have a thousand
people the rate at which they're
reproducing is going to be more or a
thousand insects it's going to be more
insects per second or per day or per
year than if you only have ten insects
so it makes sense that the rate of
growth of your population with respect
to time is going to be proportional to
your population and so you know
sometimes you think of differential
equations is these daunting complex
things but notice we've just been able
to express a a reasonably not so
complicated idea the rate of change of
population is going to be proportional
to the population and now once we've
expressed that we can actually try to
solve this differential equation find a
general solution and then we could try
to put some initial conditions on
there or some some states of the
population that we know to actually
solve for the constants to find a
particular solution so how do we do that
and I encourage you to pause the video
at any time and see if you can solve
this differential equation so assuming
you at least maybe have added attempt at
it and you might immediately recognize
that this is a separable differential
equation and in separable differential
equations we want one variable and all
the differentials involving that
variable on one side and the other
variable and all the differentials
involving the other variable on the
other side and then we can integrate
both sides and once again DP where the
rate of the derivative of P with respect
to T this isn't quite a fraction this is
the limit as our change in P over change
in time this is our instantaneous change
but for the sake of separable
differential equations or differential
equations in general you can treat you
can treat these this derivative and
liveness notations like fractions and
you can treat these differentials like
quantities because we will eventually
integrate them so let's do that so we
want to put all the peas and DP s on one
side and all the all the things that
involve T or that I guess I just don't
involve P on the other side so we could
divide both sides by P we could divide
both sides by P and so we'll have 1 over
P you have 1 over P here and then those
will cancel and then you can multiply
both sides times DT we could multiply
both sides times DT once again treating
the differential like a quantity which
isn't it really isn't a quantity
you really have to debut this as the
limit of as that change in P over change
in time the limit as we get smaller and
smaller and smaller changes in time but
for once again for the sake of this we
can do this and when we do that we would
be left with 1 over P D P is equal to is
equal to K DT is equal to K DT now we
can integrate integrate both sides
we've because
this is a this was a separable
differential equations we were able to
completely separate the P's and DPS from
things involving T's or I guess the
things that aren't involving P's and
then if we integrate this side we would
get the natural log the natural log of
the absolute value of our population and
we could say plus some constant if we
want but we're going to get a constant
on this side as well so we could just
say that's going to be equal to that's
going to be equal to K it's going to be
equal to K times T K times T plus some
constant plus some constant I'll just
call that c1 and once again I could have
put a plus c2 here but I could then
subtract the constant from both sides
and I would just get the constant on the
right-hand side now how can I solve for
P well the natural log of the absolute
value of P is equal to this thing right
over here that means that's the same
thing that means that the absolute value
of P that means that the absolute value
of P is equal to e to all of this
business e to the e to the let me do the
same colors K T KT plus plus c1 plus c1
now this right over here is the same
thing just using our exponent properties
this is the same thing as e to the KT AE
to the K times T times e times e to the
c1 e to the c1 now this is just e to
some constant so we could just call this
let's just call that the constant C so
this is all simplified to C e C e to the
KT to the K T and if we assume our
population at any given time is is
positive that we could get rid of this
absolute value sign and we have a
general solution to this frankly fairly
general differential equation we just
said proportional we haven't give
what the proportionality constant is but
we could say if we assume positive
population that the population is going
to be equal to some constant C times e
to the KT power to the KT power and the
reason why I said that you've seen this
before is this is just an exponential
function and it's very likely that an
algebra or in precalculus class you have
modeled things with exponential
functions and my guess is that you've
modeled things with populate model
things like population the reason why
this is interesting as you now see where
this is coming from the underlying logic
that's just driven by the actual
differential equation the rate of change
with respect to time of the population
well maybe it's just proportional to
population so I'll leave you there and
the next video well we'll do what you
probably did in the 10th or 11th grade
or maybe later in your life it doesn't
matter when you did it where we actually
look at some conditions to find a
particular solution